I accidentally stumbled into a four in
one day I kind of had a crush on my
brother's best friend so my girlfriend
and I followed them up there was 14
playing all the business in sweet
this isn't Sweden yeah and the name of
the town in Sweden I'm not even gonna
try to pronounce and go ahead job let
okay now we're in Sweden is this where
places two hour drive north of Stockholm
all right all right so you've got a
crush on someone and because this other
someone play pool they just kind of hung
out there once in a while played little
pool you know bowled a little they were
all athletic you know whatever they were
playing soccer and hockey and so did I
and when I walked in they had a
beautiful pool room up there as it just
turned out one of the nicest once if not
the nicest one in Sweden and they had I
think 14 Brunswick gold crown tables in
there perfect lighting and I walked in
and went wow this is this is really cool
never seen I never heard a fool in my
life before and played a couple of times
and became instantly obsessed with it
and I knew I came home after the second
time that I played I told my parents
this is what I want to do just a
fast-forward so that people understand I
mean you're a champion you have won the
women's professional billiards
Association championship you have
traveled all around the world in doing
this
did you ever think that you would be the
queen of pool or I know that your
nickname is the striking Viking of pool
that's the whole Swedish thing no I mean
you don't set out to to go I want to be
a star or I want to be you know somebody
who changes the game or a legend and
anything you set up you play because you
love it and then all this other stuff
winning championships and getting
inducted in the Hall of Fame making a
change in the sport that's something
that kind of comes as you're doing what
you already love to do what is the sport
of pool tell us a little bit about the
individual games and the scoring and so
on how can people learn more well I mean
you have three different major
in the world you have snooker which is a
very old game kind of a derived from the
same background as golf and that's
mainly played in the UK and then you
have what's called 3-cushion billiards
and that's a table with no pockets and
you play with two white balls and the
red balls a little bit different how you
score points and then you have what we
play mostly here in the United States
where if you go to two black you see the
Brunswick tables this here is a regular
standard 9 foot tournament sized pool
table obviously something that you can
find in somebody's home but this is
played either a pole or nine ball or a
game called straight-4 which are they're
the most common describe the strategy
some of the planning that goes on in
your head because I understand that it's
physics and geometry on the table but to
a certain point this is about thinking
one shot two shot many shots ahead it is
it is literally like the game of chess
in the sense that you do play ahead
usually if it's a pretty open table I
will think three to four balls ahead if
everything is wide open you initially
look I know where all nine balls are
gonna go now obviously you may have to
adjust a little bit if you get out of
line with the cue ball and kind of come
up with Plan B but yeah you really you
really do think ahead is is one of the
ways you do that by trying to introduce
the sport the sport of pool to as many
people as possible particularly outside
of let's say the United States or Europe
I know that Asia is a big area where
pool is getting to be very popular
particularly among young women young
girls yeah it's gone crazy over there
well for me it's always been a very
important part of my life because when I
played pool in Sweden nobody really said
I can't believe you're playing what kind
of you know nice girl like you doing in
a sport like this type of thing I mean
there was no reference to the hustler
movie or Jackie Gleason or Paul Newman
it didn't have that connotation not at
all like it wasn't when I when I landed
here at 17 and everybody
oh no I can't believe your flame you
know Paul and then I had my daughter
pretty young and the other parents were
kind of going like and it was it would
just drive me crazy because to me it's
the most beautiful game there is so I
couldn't quite understand okay so there
was a movie called The Hustler why does
everybody think that you know
everybody's a Minnesota Fats type you
know so I went that's kind of strange so
one of the things I said out to do is to
try to change that image and fortunately
for me that's always been the image that
Brunswick has had so when they asked me
to represent them yes since 1988 and
that it was kind of when my life changed
from going from the passion and love to
actually doing this for a living but it
also gave me the luxury of kind of
having a plateau to come to speak from I
became the president of the women's
professional billiard Association so
from there you know was able to we got
secured a contract with sponsors within
the industry secured a contract with
ESPN and we got our tour televised with
no men's tour being televised by the way
I'd add that in there so there's a huge
deal for us and explain also that there
was a situation in which because you
retained the rights to the video of the
championship outside the United States
that is something that then was able to
let you build a business exactly so we
sold the rights to to Europe to star
Asia to different areas also was shown a
lot over there and the popularity has
just gone insane especially with women
it's it's pretty amazing how popular and
men that as well but the female side of
the sport outside the United States as
well has gone just crazy when you think
of pool right now what would you like to
see happen and let's say the next five
years well I mean I think that's really
close to my heart is is the people
having a table in their home you know I
see with with all my friends and
and my kitten daughter and is instead of
just sitting in front of the television
playing it's the greatest family game if
you can't be outside throwing a football
or going for a run or whatever in your
inside there's no better way to to get
together than to get to get around a
full table and so that one has become
pretty interesting the we had a an
outlet called Brunswick game on and it's
a it's a website where you can go on and
learn about the game and I have a lot of
videos on there to kind of show how you
can teach your kids a trick shot is
there something about the green do you
recall throughout your career not that
it's over at all but I mean that you
remember that the Green itself creates
some feeling inside you yeah there's
kind of a peace there a lot of times we
use blue now because it shows up better
on television but to me this is what if
their pool table should look like you
know that that warm green color that's
that's it's kind of it puts you in that
in that place and that's what another
thing that I thought was sexy when I
first walked into that pool Romania in
my hometown in Sweden was it's kind of a
darker room with these lights over the
table so it's kind of a stage with the
balls and the green cloth and everything
and then that's part of what helped me I
think you know I couldn't let billiards
champion Ava Lawrence get away without
showing me some of the skills that have
made her the best in the world and after
we spoke we had what you can call a pool
party perhaps
the main thing is that when you're down
shooting and when you're at address that
this arm is straight up and down so if
the cue if the cue is too short for
instance you're holding it back here you
don't want to have that adjusted so you
can have a nice smooth follow-through
I'd say to people don't hold it you you
cradle the kid cradled the queue does
all the work as you can see I don't hold
anything all I'm doing is staring at
that before letting acute kind of do the
work
anywhere from here to here is the best
place to break the balls from you don't
really want to break them here because
you want to get kind of a push and have
a chance for more balls doesn't matter
that it's super hard you want to get a
solid hit like that I'm straight on it
in trickshot the setup is very important
and then having somebody obviously
showed you how to how to shoot it
you forgot it